[Music]
let's go to lisa in hilton head back to
south carolina in the south hey lisa
what's up
hi how are you good sorry i don't know
how to work the phones i'm figuring it
out
that's okay what's up how's it going
good good we have a college freshman a
rising college freshman who is due to
move into his dorm in literally two
weeks
and has recently come to us and said he
is not sure
he is ready to go to college yet and
would maybe possibly like to take a
semester to a year off and work instead
um a little background about him is he's
had a full-time job since he graduated
from high school and has loved working
he loves he loves working full-time he
loves making money he's also
a kid that doesn't like changes so
he's always had to be nudged a little to
take risks and do new things and um
i guess my question is my husband and i
really value education and we've we know
that it's much more than just a degree
it's learning to live on your own
learning to live in a dorm with other
people
and we want him not to miss out on that
experience
but i guess
we want to know how to support him to
make a good decision without pushing him
in one direction or the other
i love this question lisa so one thanks
for caring enough about your son to be
thinking this way and two thanks for
calling and asking
um i often marvel at my parents i tried
to quit high school athletics when i was
a freshman
and they said no they wouldn't let me
quit
and i got all been out of shape and bob
ended up being the greatest decision
ever
things i did this morning
in my like the exercises i did this
morning
um the seeds were planted back when i
was in high school and my little brother
quit when he was a freshman
they let him
i got so mad i was i think i was in
college i think i was at the freshman
college like you're letting him quit
ridiculous he's a different kid with
different experiences and different
right and they somehow knew the
difference and it was a great right
decision for him
and so um
and he was working out this morning in
the gym too and we right so all i have
to say is this that's a great intuitive
question
um
just my gut reaction having worked with
countless college students and countless
college parents
my gut reaction to this situation right
now is
uh-huh and say
um we're gonna give you an off-ramp if
you want it
right okay
um there's something about
um
i'm doing this with my daughter now um
she would prefer she was a covet kid
right so performative years um
preschool kindergarten was all at home
and masked up and so now the world's
back open and it's like hey you gotta
take do an instrument you're gonna have
to do jiu jitsu or a sport and she's
like i'd rather just sit at home in
color
and so like right so i have to say okay
do this but in three three months we're
going to give it 90 days and then if
you're done you're done i'm good with
that but i want you to try new things of
course you went to her first piano
lesson and loved every set right so
i think you are right
to say
um we totally hear you
we're gonna make you a deal we're not
gonna hold it over your head and we're
not gonna go bananas if you go for one
semester and say i'm out i can't do this
um we'll check in with you we'll drive
down to wherever school is for um in one
month and 30 days and we'll take you out
to dinner and we're going to get a pulse
on how things are going
right and maybe some some notes on the
calendar along the way that give him
some landmarks right
um that might be real helpful and maybe
he has to do a couple of things you're
gonna have to get involved in one one
group
like you have to do one thing right with
one group of wackadoo college students
uh you can't just go in the room and
play halo and then in
september say you hate it you want to
come home
right right maybe he's got to get a job
college college is what you make it so
you can make it great and get involved
and get out of your comfort zone and do
things um
and they will you'll look back on those
and those will be the greatest
experiences that you ever had but you
wouldn't have had them had you not
pushed yourself so but let me let me
catch you on two things
it was your greatest experience ever
and it might be miserable for him so we
have to hold that loosely right
um
going to big crazy concerts with the
crowd is all chaotic those are some of
my most formative wonderful memories my
son doesn't like it doesn't like it that
much and i keep saying yeah but if you
just go do it and finally it's like oh
no he's a different right does that make
sense so that your experience was the
most formative incredible and you see
other kids have it that doesn't mean
it's his
um the other thing is
um it's college is gonna be what you
make of it
is a really intimidating um
layout for sure it's intimidating
landscape to someone who's had their
school lives curated their home lives
curated their work life's curated
they've never had to make it they don't
have that skill
you know what i'm saying right so it's
like putting somebody in the batter's
box of a major league picture and saying
just swing the bat it's like that ball's
coming 90 miles an hour i don't know
what to do with that right so it can
feel very much that way so when we say
it is going to be what you make of it i
going back to what i said earlier break
it down
once you get involved in one group
i want you to um i'm going to put a
little bit extra money in your account
and i want you once a week you and your
roommate just go hang out go to dinner
on me right
um
in october by october one you need to
have a job a part-time job somewhere in
the community
and let's right let's let's get involved
with the film club get involved with the
drama club get involved with the
intramurals or whatever you got to do
one thing sure and right that's
different than it's gonna be what you
make of it i don't even know what that
means right right
okay that's good advice as a high school
kid
everything i was all about making it i i
was all about it is going to be what i
make of it i knew what that meant um
other people that i loved didn't don't
have the skills for that and it's that's
fine i didn't have skills for sitting
down and studying and paying attention
um i was too busy uh having it be what i
made of it right right
exactly here's the the
you said something earlier that
oh it's gonna be hard for you and your
husband and this is tough
[Music]
you two value education in a major way i
value education i spent my life doing it
my wife's is a life a lifelong educator
um
here's here's how much we value it our
son told us for i don't never mind i
don't want to say private stuff
i could just say i looked at my wife and
i was like this is what happens with
nerds raising nerds right um
we value education i also have to know
that my son may come to me one day and
say i want to be a diesel mechanic i'm
gonna be the best damn diesel mechanic
that's ever list existed
and i'm gonna take him out to dinner and
say
awesome
right and i have pictures of him playing
frisbee on the lawn at stanford the
chances of that happening are very slim
sure right um and it won't be
intellectual it won't be like his his
brain capacity it's gonna be what his
life wants to look like
um so you guys value it very very much i
would say it might look different it
education just simply looks different in
many corners of the world this these
days
so don't hold your son hostage to
your dreams are you more so your picture
of what you think his life is going to
look like
right that makes sense and that's so
hard absolutely yes it is hard because
you want them
of course you want the best for them you
want them to to
do well and
be successful and whatever that looks
like whether it's working or college or
or
what have you but
um but here here's the thing though
parents we we don't get credit for this
um and i think i've talked about this on
the show here one of the
uh if you had to have me distill down
one of the top two or three moments i've
been most proud of my son
he came to me and my wife at christmas
last year
and
said i need to have a family
conversation i think i mentioned on the
show i was like thinking in my head are
you already smoking like really you're
12 right
and he sat us down me and my wife and he
said i would like to ask to not play
baseball this spring but instead i want
to
i want to be in the school play i want
to do theater oh
and
yes i i did theater in college my whole
career is based on on acting and theater
like i i was like yes
and uh-huh my granddad played baseball
my dad played baseball i played baseball
right and it hit me
oh crap this would be the first spring
we don't do baseball like a delony guys
right and so i had to i had for without
even thinking about it
i had created a world where this is what
our life is going to look like and my 12
year old son bravely sat down and said i
wanted to look like something different
and so it's both and
i as a parent get to grieve the fact
that it's i had a picture and it's going
to be different
right i get that if your son says does a
semester in college and he's and he
makes straight c's and he said guys
right now i'm 18.
this isn't it for me i want to go to
mechanics does he have something else in
mind he wants to do
well he he his passion is film and
writing scripts and um doing uh like
editing and there is a there is a school
out of state
much more out of our budget and so
that's not really an option right now it
could be down the road if he wants to
work and
match the
you know remaining portion to be able to
go there
um
but to be able to go there immediately
out of high school was not going to be
an option and i think there is some
immense value um in
like a screenwriter's gotta learn how to
write
first
right and a
videographer often has to learn what a
story is what an arc is and
take a psychology class and a counseling
class and be around wackadoo people and
how to manage artists to write all those
things
so i would tell you a and by the way you
can't afford it so that is what it is
right
i think there's a way
whether there's a film major or a way to
be involved in that
to get into your local theater program
there's a way to get into your local
fill in the blanks right right there's a
way to get that experience
while also
getting your feet underneath you
yeah as a freshman in college right
right so it's not an either or is what
i'm saying um yes and it sounds like
based on what you told me about him it
sounds like
he's just getting really cold feet and
he's got a got another idea
right right yes i think i think the fact
that he's enjoyed working and the fact
that he likes making money and he knows
what his goal is as far as careers down
the road
he's kind of thought well i don't want
to waste your money and go into
this school when maybe i should just go
and save my money until i can go to the
other school but we told them
you know get your degree or at least get
two years under your belt
at the in-state you know more affordable
school and then you can re-evaluate you
know from there yeah i'm a big believer
and i i get some pushback on this i got
colleagues that disagree with me that's
fine that's totally fine
um
i don't believe
in the phrase those uh that education
was wasted
right um people often tell me like i was
so stupid i got a degree in teaching and
now i do this i was such a waste and i
tell him it was not a waste
right i agree 100 with that yes even if
it was finding out if you if you told
somebody hey it's going to cost you this
much money
to find out something that you never
ever ever want to be a part of
and sometimes that's a good investment
right right sure because i spent a lot
of money chasing things that i'm like i
wish i i wasn't doing that all to say
right
often the idea that was a waste of time
as a waste of money is a is a frame of
mind
right my first phd in education was
absolutely i'm not doing it i'm not
using it at all
and it was one of the most valuable
experiences of my life
right right and so it's just yeah it's
it it it's essentially priceless you're
exactly right but i could also say what
a waste of time what a waste of money
that was so stupid it wasn't um right
but i'm not i'm not technically using it
but i'm using it every second of every
day right all i have to say is you know
that i'm just i'm that's more for the
listener um and i do have a immense bias
towards education i do um and there's
there's a truth there so you're calling
me ask my opinion i am biased um i also
have worked with thousands of 18 year
olds
and man they get nervous they get scared
and they think
right and i think
parental wisdom especially not
parental insane demands and parental
rights you're going to be a lawyer
because it's going to make me feel right
that's not what you're doing
you're saying i know my kid you need to
go ahead and do this
yeah right yeah and i think that's a lot
that's great advice with with a
circling back to very beginning
let's put some markers on a piece of
paper we're gonna come visit you on this
day and this day and this day you're
gonna have to let us know a group you've
joined by this day
um if you are in the film club or in the
theater department or whatever we're
going to come see you um whatever
productions you do um and you and your
husband like hey we got a budget for
this and figure this out because we're
going to go be involved here and you
come home at christmas and sit down and
write us a three-page essay on why this
isn't for you we're going to read it
we're taking you out to a fancy dinner
and then we're going to go look at other
schools we're going to go look at other
things perfect does that make sense it's
a perfect plan yes absolutely thank you
for that you're so great lisa wisdom i
appreciate it he is lucky lucky to have
you parents all parents listening
it is
so okay it's not it matters okay it's
right it's good to have a vision a
picture of your kid's life
it's also good and right to say i know
you don't quote unquote feel like doing
this i'm your parent this is what we're
doing right now
and it's also wise and good to give your
kids choices and options and exit
strategies
we often make them either or
either i go to film school or i do this
uh
i want you to try this
i want you to practice this i want you
to lean into this be curious about this
i'm gonna foot the bill i'm gonna help
out and if it doesn't work i'm going to
high five you we're going to throw a
party and then we're going to turn left
and at that and we're going to turn
right
but i want you to have these experiences
and i'm your parent that's my job is to
be wise and to continue to speak into
your life there's a reason why
culturally
all across the world
there's not a mad release of 18 year
olds into the world
there is mandatory military service
there is additional education
there is a
a
time a natural time when there is begins
to be a separation where somebody begins
to find their adult footing
it doesn't have to be college it doesn't
have to be a four year university it
doesn't have to be an ivy league school
absolutely not um
it can be a i'm taking a year and in
this year i'm just going to work man i'm
18. i'm just going to work at mcdonald's
i'm just going to work down the street
i'm going to get my feet under me i'm
going to learn some skills i'm going to
learn some tasks and mom and dad i'm
going to be hyper intentional we're
going to go to lunch once a week and
we're going to just talk about how
you're developing and growing we're
going to read some books together we're
going to do some developmental things or
you're going straight to the military
you're going to learn some discipline
you're going to learn under the wisdom
and tutelage and experiences of other
adults in your life
but this idea that you turn 18 you're
free to run the world it's not safe it's
not smart and it doesn't make any sense
and culturally for bajillions of years
we've
we've understood this innately and over
the last 15 20 years we've just said hey
do whatever you want to whatever feels
good and this also works in reverse by
the way some kid says i'm going to mit
i'm going to mt i'm going to mit there
comes a moment as a parent and you look
at your kid and say i know you you're
not
or if you want to pay for it you can
walk out the front door i can't keep you
from doing it but it's not wise for you
the wisest choice for you is x and y and
there's all these stories of the kids
they're like i'm doing it anyway and
they go on and start a company and make
a billion dollars there's a million of
those
i've set with there's a few of those
i've sat with countless folks
countless over the years in my office
behind closed doors
heartbroken young people heartbroken
parents who tried to force a thing that
wasn't forcible
all i'd say is be intense with your kid
have them try things and also give them
off ramps most importantly be
intentional be intentional be
intentional